[Music]
now that's a man with abs a nice deal
Kelly Ripa took to Instagram Wednesday
to show off her hubby Mark Consuelos and
his killer core strength she posted this
video with the caption quote how about a
little hashtag workout motivation for
the extremely thirsty
hashtag workout hashtag daddy if you
look closely at the mirror you can see
the talk-show hosts filming the
shirtless and sweaty actor as Madonna's
2008 track she's not me
jams out in the background celebrities
were quick to chime in in the comments
section
banking kelly for the workout motivation
lisa rinna hilariously wrote hashtag
daddy in ABC's David Muir gush saying
quote that's insane I have a lot of work
to do before I see y'all but it seems
the only comment mark was looking out
for was from their daughter Lola the dad
of three wrote that he was quote waiting
for the 18 year old to reply to the post
because of course who could forget when
this happened she opened the door and it
was like it was a late morning and it
was Father's Day and we see the door
open
and she goes I mean and she's like
thanks a lot my birthday she shuts the
door on you here you just ruined my
birthday
Kelly's sweaty Fitness vid comes about a
week after she posted this family photo
which pretty much confirms mark is aging
backwards yeah he fed down with a couple
last year and they opened up about their
approach to social media you know I
guess yes it's it we walk this fine line
of respecting our kids which is a
privacy that's privacy yet also we
always have we have no respect we've
heard you know
[Music]